hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow midseason finale video so
much we need to talk about I feel like
the collective audience just absolutely
died you could see the moment on Twitter
when everyone saw it and then just boom
just bomb exploded everywhere right away
just need to remember the arrows coming
back episode 10 is gonna air on January
21st the flash is coming back that week
too don't worry I will totally be doing
bonus videos until it gets here so feel
free to leave requests ok so so many
things we need to talk about so careful
for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet starting with top
five moments number five Thea really is
the killer this was definitely one of
the bigger theories early on most of the
people that didn't believe it just
didn't think that she could make the
trip from corto matys they kind of
brushed over it in the episode but if
you want to think about it this way Thea
had just been in Starling longer than
she let on I think the timing was what
confused a lot of people she wasn't one
of my higher picks I'd say of all the
people that I thought she beat I thought
it either be cut Anna or someone from
the league a couple of weeks ago I kind
of picked up on the Batman racial Ghul
plot so I thought that they might frame
him and that would be like the big WTF
twist but they kind of threw that away
like the minute that Felicity says
you're the one that did this they just
immediately dismiss it and say no no no
someone's trying to frame us it would
have been fun if they would have left
some doubt in that but I think they just
wanted to speed past it and get to that
duel on the mountaintop as fast as
possible if you ever wonder why
something really interesting happens and
they just brush over it it's usually in
the name of expediency like they have
something more important that they're
trying to get to the real question is
will Thea ever find out that she did it
think about what Roy is going through
right now thinking about killing that
police officer he's probably gonna
continue to deal with that for the rest
of the season
we haven't got a lot of Roy solo scenes
but I think now given that Stephen Amell
is gonna be sitting a few episodes out
we will get more Roy time and I'll
explain why Stephen Amell is gonna be
sitting a few episodes out in a second
Merlyn said that the drug used to whammy
Thea leaves the victims with no memory
of what they've done it remains to be
seen whether or not that'll stick so
we'll just keep your eyes peeled if Thea
starts to have flashbacks or
hallucinations I'm actually pretty happy
I think this is a good direction for her
character the other question now is who
drugged her it's either China white and
she's gonna come into the present-day
storyline or it's gonna turn out to be
someone from the league like it'll be
racial goal behind it number four Masayo
is part
of the league now this is actually a
huge moment they'd spoiled it in the
teaser for the episode last week we knew
who's gonna be part of the League of
Assassins this is a giant twist on the
katana origin story so in the comics
katana
is the big character her husband is the
one that gets murdered she goes on to
become the katana character with the
sole blade I think the reason they
changed this is because of casting
issues originally they cast Devon Aoki
as the katana character I think they had
attended for her to become katana but
then she dropped out of the project and
then a new actress stepped in so I think
they just switched things up a little
bit and gave Karl Yune that part or it's
possible that they never intended that
from the beginning like they always
intended for Masayo to be the character
to cross over into present-day either
way they did kind of do the katana
origin story but they twisted it and
Masao became the katana character China
white did reference the sword in their
apartment so I feel like that's a nod to
katanas Blade you guys can let me know
whether or not you would have rather
seen katana I mean usually I mean that's
a pretty easy answer usually most people
want to see the comic book character I
feel like Karl Yune is a great actor
though so I think it's gonna be fine he
seemed pretty brainwashed for the first
part of the episode later though when he
talks to Oliver about getting his
effects in order he seems like he has
his [ __ ] together number 3
Laurel explains the Black Canary to her
mother I was so happy when I saw River
Song was coming back in the episode and
how Bish's was she wow she said make
them pay make them suffer that is such a
River Song thing to say she is a badass
[ __ ] to be fair though I feel like most
mothers would react this way so I don't
think it's a Doctor Who easter egg or
anything like that I think it's just
something naturally a really angry
person would say so many secrets going
around though secrets being kept from
Thea secrets be kept from Oliver secrets
being kept from Captain Lance I don't
think Alex Kingston is coming back
really soon I do hope that she comes
back before the season 3 finale as for
Laurel Black Canary stuff yes we will
see her in the costume in the next
couple of episodes there was a picture
that posted of her with Roy this seems
like it's gonna be going down when
Oliver is not around number 2 Ray Palmer
shows off the atom suit to Felicity and
explains his backstory so we learned the
tragic history it wasn't his wife it was
his fiancee that died I think that's
just because the age of the character
down in the comics he was married and we
found out what's going on with Omak so
it's it's very different in the comics
but Omak in the arrowverse is just that
one suit or
they were intending to mass-produce the
suit insults to the military or
something like that Ray Palmer is just
marrying that project to his technology
of miniaturization Marc Guggenheim
already said they're not gonna shrink
him on the show but that was a long time
ago he said he recently changed his mind
about Paris on arrow
it's possible they could not shrink him
but they could do some sort of Adam
powers he did say he was gonna try and
do some super powers and that might
include the back half of the season but
typically when you think powers you're
thinking like firestorm you're thinking
like metahumans so we'll see I would
like to see them do Adam powers before
they bring a whole bunch of other comic
book characters on the show I have no
idea which episode is gonna actually
feature the physical costume I would say
sometime before the finale like sometime
in the middle of the second half of the
season sometime later than that and I
know people keep asking but I will say
yes I do think that he's going to fight
with team arrow before the end of the
season he's almost been in the cave
already I mean he was on top of it I
will be interested to see whether or not
Felicity brings him in or if he comes in
on his own like if he sneaks in given
that Oliver's gonna be out of commission
it's possible that Felicity could kind
of co-opt his services to help out he
could kind of be the stand-in for Oliver
while he's not around that is an
interesting thought there are a number
of other superheroes on the show that
they have superhero characters think of
it is like Superman or Batman going away
in the Justice Society coming in and
forming to fill the void we do have
Wildcat we have Merlin even though he's
technically not a good character he
could help them out and then now we have
Ray Palmer the atom with the atom suit
once it's finished all very exciting
Stephen Amell says a lot of Justice
League TV showed things I think it's
more like Justice Society interesting to
note Geoff Johns and Marc Guggenheim
have both written Justice Society the
comic book Marc Guggenheim is the
showrunner for arrow and Geoff Johns has
written a couple of our episodes but he
mostly works on the flash so think of
arrow is doing a version of Justice
Society this year and my number one WTF
moment easy Rochelle Goyle kills Oliver
Queen
the real question isn't whether or not
Oliver's dead the question is is how is
he going to come back and is it going to
be the Lazarus Pit Marc Guggenheim has
kind of stepped around the idea of the
Lazarus Pit he did say that they would
try to do things but he didn't confirm
anything because of Eros stance on doing
superpowers and because that's changing
it's totally possible that they could
have dipped all of her in the Lazarus
Pit the other possibility is that he's
on the edge of death and he's going to
recuperate it's going to be a
like a Dark Knight Rises situation for
Christian Bale got thrown in that
version of the lazarus pit and had to
climb his way out after he healed I have
also heard a crazy fan theory that
sounds kind of interesting I don't know
if it's true that Rachel Ghul and Oliver
were working together the whole time and
they just made it look like rage killed
Oliver he ran him through the stomach he
didn't run him through his heart like he
didn't chop his head off and we did see
rage climbing out of a very
interesting-looking bath the first time
we saw him the other theory that's a
little bit better is that this whole
season has been an adaptation of the
Batman daughter of the demons storyline
in that story
rachelle ghoul engineers this plot to
get Batman to take over the League of
Assassins because Talia is in love with
him so he chooses him as a worthy
successor arrow obviously a lot of
details have been changed miss al Ghul's
the stand-in for Talia and she's in love
with Sara who's dead not Oliver we don't
know enough about Rachael ghoul to know
whether or not he wants Oliver to take
over and we don't know how China white
is involved let me know that what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and here's the big question how do you
think that Oliver is going to come back
so here's the deal with all of her being
away for a few episodes during the
middle of the season he had a nine day
break normally that's unheard of so I
think he's only gonna be gone for an
episode and a half normally it takes him
about a week to film an episode that's
why I say if he's gone for a full week
or a little bit more than a full week he
could have filmed some scenes for say
like episode 11 or here's a really crazy
idea they could just show him in
flashbacks like that's how he could be
in all the episodes and then he'll
reappear at the end of the season in
present-day so he could be gone in
present-day
for the rest of the season that'd be
crazy I do think he'll come back before
then though it is too huge for them to
not milk that in reality he will be dead
to the world for a little while just
like he was dead when he was on the
island overall I gave the episode a
solid a I totally loved the chance they
took they killed their main star how
many shows have the guts to do that yes
it's a comic book show
no one ever truly dies in the comics
let's talk about Stephen Amell
performance I feel like this season has
stretched his ability as an actor more
than any other season I think he did a
great job Oliver is a very naturally
reserved character emotionally so that
is why you don't see him crying his eyes
out all the time right on the other hand
I could totally see him crying his eyes
out I bet he cries a little bit about
Thea every once in a while we didn't see
a lot from
but I am so interested to see what
happens whenever she comes back on that
Black Canary costume Felicity in that I
love you moment that was so great I feel
like her scenes with Ray Palmer were
very interesting they did convey a lot
of information from the comic books very
exciting but I feel like her Oliver
scenes are always the most meaningful
always the most rewarding for viewers
and I love the way he casually just said
I love you and they said okay bye see
you later
no big deal see it a couple episodes
it's just gonna be an amazing reaction
shot when they see Oliver arise like a
phoenix I mean really in terms of
plotting there are more questions than
answers right now but it's only the
first half of the season this episode
was just meant to throw us into the
action of what the rest of the year's
gonna be namely this big China white
bio-weapon thing and the League of
Assassins with Rachel Ghul
I thought the editing was great I love
the way that they jumped forward and
backwards in time normally we just get
the flashbacks this time they would jump
forward almost every time we got a
flashback
we got a flash-forward I love the way
that they play with that in the fight
scene I mean yeah Oliver clearly was not
gonna be able to take Rea shot goal no
matter what even if he did throw the
fight which I don't think that he did
that's up to debate I will be so
interested if it turns out that they
were working together the whole time
what I'm waiting for now though is a
shot of Oliver climbing back up there
and yanking the sword out of the stone
that's a very King Arthur type situation
don't you just see that happening like
them giving Oliver that storyline
pulling the literal Excalibur out of the
stone Excalibur drenched in blood his
own blood for that matter so like I said
I will be doing bonus videos in the off
season so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
feel free to leave me requests you know
stuff about the atom about any other
secondary characters or other characters
that I want to see on the show I will be
doing a Q&A for this so feel free to
leave any question you want about the
flash or arrow or anything else Justice
League related even Suicide Squad and
one more time the flash is coming back
January twentieth arrow coming back the
21st right now though if you're in your
mobile phone or on your tablet you can
click up here for extra links it's the
same as the links over here but right
now click here for my flash finale video
and click here for all my other arrow
bonus videos thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five I will
see you guys tomorrow
Dorrie it'll be okay everybody go take a
bath in the Lazarus Pit
you